having another relapse
so sick of this
I'm Rollin manthpop I'm technology
correspondent Sky News our technology
correspondent Roland manthorpe has an
exclusive story our analysis which looks
at all
um well I was technology correspondent
at Sky News I still am officially
but
um I've been off work
pretty much consistently for
18 months
I'm also a dad I've got uh two children
and a wonderful partner I'm Kirsten and
I'm Roland's partner and I'm a long
habitat
here are
all the pills now I'm feeling a bit
better I want to try and explore
this illness this problem
why don't we know more about it these
syndromes have never been properly
researched and other people having the
same problems that I had
a lot of doctors don't believe
that Long Cove is a thing other people
being you know to be honest let down
I had a cough
and
it wasn't that bad you know I took a day
off work
kind of a drag
then
just suddenly I I woke up and
everything was different the difference
was just massive it was like from
someone who was kind of
um
processing a lot really busy loads of
energy long days all the stuff into
someone who looked totally gray like
could not kind of take on complicated
like um analysis or thought or like
concentration really um in any sustained
way at all and um and who just like had
at first like no energy for anything
I opened the book and the words were
just swimming in front of my eyes
and I had to say I'm so sorry already
I can't I can't read it to you you know
even these these like tiny lines in
really big prints too much for me
it was only
once we were about
three months in that I remember having
this moment and thinking
oh my God I thought it was gonna be
better by now like I really thought this
was going to be over
you know you can always if you need it
you think you could always find energy
and suddenly you can't
yeah if you're going to the red zone you
you completely collapse then you pay for
it
now probably
instead of jumped I mean things are a
lot better now and they have been a lot
better but that basic equation that
hasn't gone away
I've got limited energy
I take longer to recharge than I used to
I can't push myself yes
probably just being
pushed a little bit too far
and then I started to realize that I was
part of a mass disabling event it's
thought there could be as many as half a
million people suffering from long
covered in the UK according to research
by campaigners there are more than 80
000 children in England living with long
covid in terms of long covered it's
caused Devastation we have two million
people living with long covet many of
them are disabled this could devastate
our Health Service this could devastate
our Healthcare provision this could
drain our economy this could knock
millions of people out of work this in
itself is a healthcare emergency I spoke
to the GP about it and he advised me to
do this thing graded exercise
which is where you push yourself a
little bit more each day and if as soon
as you said that
it felt wrong I I felt like no this
every time I push myself even the
tiniest little bit like we're talking a
long walk then I come back and I
completely collapse
just walking back from the shops
and
I'm out of energy already and then when
I looked it up loads of people who'd had
chronic fatigue syndrome or me or
anything like this we're saying this is
the worst idea you must not do this you
think do you think that's right the rest
is really the key I think I can't
emphasize sufficiently how important
rest is so um
you know increasingly we're we're trying
to um get on with our lives aren't we
and ignore covid and ignore covid
infections and reinfections and so part
and parcel of that is oh just ignore it
and you know power through it I can only
say that that's really the worst thing
you could do
I wanted to know if other people were
getting the wrong advice so I went to
Victoria
13 has had long covered for 15 months
then when I went back to school I
couldn't do more than two days a week
without having to rest before
I was just always doing stuff that was
like just easy for a normal person but
it felt like I was
just walking felt like I was running a
marathon all the time
how much can you manage in a day
not a lot if it's a good day I might be
able to go out but I'll still need a
wheelchair
she was learning the cello she was
helping out her old brownie pack she was
a guide she was doing life saving so
open water in the pool doing extra
Mandarin lessons at school just really
really busy so full of life just on the
verge of spreading her wings and then
this is just kind of so and it's one of
my toddler alike she's gone back to
yeah she's a shell now are you getting
any support you know from the NHS for
example not really
um our GPS been great
um other professionals not so we've had
lots of she's anxious that's why her
vision's going or she's depressed so
she's a shower she needs to go for a
walk from others
I waited
15 months I think it was
C
a specialist
just about to head off to the long cover
Clinic
I don't want to get my hopes up
but I kind of
really need some help and then when I
arrived they well they told me there
wasn't any treatment
so I got leaflets
caring for yourself after covert 19. I
mean I had coffee 18 months ago here's
another one how to conserve your energy
it's sleep hygiene the GP information
sheet he was pretty frustrated because
he said the doctor's really nice they
really listening to me but they don't
have anything to offer
back to square one I guess
and I've done so many so many treatments
well here are
all the pills
I've taken for long covered
and let me tell you
not one
not one has worked Rollins sort of um
attempts to kind of recover and find
things where this
um series of quite DIY
magic beans sort of like possibilities
it's a hyperbaric chamber and basically
they're going to suck all the pressure
out or depressurize it to help oxygen
more oxygen get into my blood get into
my brain because the idea is that with
long covered you're not getting enough
oxygen to your brain
that's part of the problem thanks
to be clear self-medicating can be
dangerous and you shouldn't be doing
anything without proper medical advice
the long-covered agenda has been led by
patients it hasn't been led by doctors
or scientists
um you know they're the ones who told us
what this thing is and what they were
suffering and they're also very
um desperate and impatient and irritated
and can't understand why medicine and
medical research moves at such a glacial
pace and a very motivated to do what I
would call n equals one do-it-yourself
experiments on themselves sometimes in
very dangerous ways
I listen to animal treatment
like obviously it's new
you know covered was new and within a
year we had three four even amazing
vaccines it feels like
we started from scratch instead of
starting with an existing knowledge base
so I'm on the train I'm gonna see a man
who can understand why
I was a perfectly fit young adult I was
in my early 30s I'd never had any health
problems at all in my life and I was
working as a very busy Junior doctor in
science Esther hospital
I caught a dose of chickenpox from one
of my patients then what happened was
the chickenpox went away
um but I didn't recover
I have this cluster of very typical
symptoms which is this activity-induced
fatigue this brain fog problems with
short-term memory concentration so it
was the whole gamut of symptoms of of me
long covid and at that point
Emmy was regarded as hysterical nonsense
by the medical profession because what
listening to you I'm really struck by is
you had your illness in the late 70s and
40 years later I've had something pretty
much identical
and in the intervening time span
almost nothing has happened we know
almost nothing more about these diseases
okay so so this is the chart which
illustrates the disparity of research
funding for mecfs over here compared to
a number of long-term medical conditions
if the bar
for CFS was as big as the bar for
rheumatoid arthritis could we
have a treatment for long covet we could
have treatments effective treatments for
these for for this condition what we've
had is a period of tremendous missed
opportunity because of lack of Interest
lack of funding all I'd say kind of in
defense of the medical research
Community is you know give us a break
because covid went on to the fast
forward and because of you know the need
and heat of battle we went from a
standing start to vaccines and an
incredible amount of knowledge in you
know nine to 12 months
um long covid is incredibly complex
um multi-system multi-organ
um and we are trying to race forward and
understanding it but it might take a
little bit longer I do I do think all
the right stuff is being done I feel
like I'm really starting to understand
now why there isn't a treatment for
people like me
um which is great you know uh yeah
curiosity satisfied
um but it does also really bring home
the kind of cold hard reality that
unless the research massively ramps up
there probably won't be a treatment for
me for I mean I don't know years decades
so
uh you know in reality
I think that all I can do is just focus
on managing my symptoms
I think the thing that made the biggest
difference for a Roland was that he had
a support and especially and from
a health coach through his work it was
somebody who listened to you believed
you helped you to think about
um
how to go about things as you recover
how to sort of pace things properly not
to take on too much and and that was so
crucial when I heard that I was going to
get a health coach I've got like I've
got to be honest I rolled my eyes
because I'm like uh I you know I'm a
grown-up I think I can I organize my own
time I mean how how hard can it be
um but I couldn't
I couldn't because I just want to do
that a little bit more I can hear the
battle the tussle the the tug of war
um what we're going to be doing is
helping you to um be open to that
experience be aware of it and helping
you to move on and improve your
functioning
and accepting the situation and working
with it
look at me out and about
you know it's kind of boring being
careful all the time but Pace actually
works
instead optimism it's totally terrible
there is so much that we can help people
with long covered
um understand from the point of view of
help with management of these you know
crucial key symptoms all around me I do
see people who are very very slowly you
know getting back on their bicycles
getting back on their Marathon running
and regaining their old lives okay
basically couldn't be 12. I couldn't I
won't really be 13 I can't get it back
and it's it's sad but at the same time I
know it really helped in the future
because I'll be able to do other stuff
and know that it can be hard but I can
get through this
[Music]
what I've realized is that I'm not
better
and I might never be better
but
if I look after myself and do all the
right things and manage my energy
then
I can work
and
enjoy things and I can
live
and I've got a lot to live for don't I
that's not everything I wanted but that
is something
it's just so important that everyone
knows that not just long covered
sufferers but everyone
because we need help
[Music]
bless you
[Music]
um